hey everybody welcome to the great big
story youtube channel i'm dave and i'm
jillian welcome to the show
we're meeting four people who have a
love for something and share it with
people around them and they're really
good at it like this first guy who
crawls into bear dens for conservation
efforts in utah and there are baby bears
coming up everybody get ready get ready
cuteness overload
[Music]
growing up in montana i feel like i had
kind of a special opportunity just to
be outside a lot that's kind of where a
lot of wildlife started for me that dies
out and a lot of kids and for me it just
continued all right guys so we just
finished up the dan
this little guy hasn't been named yet
[Music]
my name is wesley larson i'm a master's
student working in wildlife conservation
and in uh some circles i'm known as
grizzkid
when i first started deciding that i
should get into the wildlife field i
found uh dr tom smith at byu i started
by working with polar bears uh on
alaska's north slope and then that kind
of transitioned into some black bear
work down here in utah in bryce canyon
bryce canyon like other national parks
that do have bears they've had a kind of
a history with with visitor conflict and
with bears that maybe are getting into
campsites so what we're doing is we're
tracking the bears to learn what
habitats they're using just to see what
the park could do better to make it
easier for visitors
to avoid bears
what we're doing is we're fitting black
bears with gps collars and then i'll go
into the den
with the bear
to um inject it with some drugs the bear
then falls asleep i can pull it out and
you know just give it a full checkup
it's
probably the most scary thing we do just
because bears wake up sometimes they're
really unhappy to see us stay stay stay
get the backpack
[Music]
hey
stay
[Music]
back
i have had to crawl up trees after bears
it's it's an interesting job for sure
people do have this knee-jerk reaction
to see an animal that's sedated or an
animal that's wearing a collar and think
that you know it might be being hurt and
the thing that they don't realize is
that we really care about these animals
probably more than just about anyone
getting out into the wilderness and
having these kind of experiences helps
you understand that
we depend on wildlife and wildlife
depends on us and that's really what
conservation is all about giving the
space and the respect to these animals
that they deserve and really learning as
much about them as we can
[Music]
next up we're going to meet billy
mitchell who was named the video game
player of the century he is the pac-man
champion let's go check out his great
big story
i'm billy mitchell video game player of
the century
i did the world's first perfect score on
pac-man 3
three thousand three hundred and sixty
oh it's exhausting to just say it
i began in the competitive world of
pinball
it moved to donkey kong
but the greatest level of competition at
the moment was pac-man
if i was going to be the best i had to
be the best at the game that was
everywhere so in 1999 i sent out a press
release i was as cocky as could be they
said there's been 10 billion games
played how are you going to do it i says
because i'm billy mitchell
you start off on the first board but on
board 21 that's where it reaches maximum
difficulty you have to navigate all the
way to board 255
doing the same repetitive thing you
can't miss a dot a prize a blue man you
can't die once
you can't lose focus you gotta stay with
it all the way there four to five hours
you have to take a corner down to one
sixtieth of a second
in order to create perfect timing and
keep your eye right here right here
you have to do that over 29 thousand
times
without making any mistakes and dying
you play 255 boards on 256 there's
enough memory left in the game for the
left half of the board and not the right
half
the right half is filled with computer
garble anything and everything that is
not packed in different walls different
dots
that's what a perfect score is
the moment that score went up there
i thought wow i achieved perfection
you get to the end there's nothing to do
but die there was nothing saying
congratulations there was nothing saying
the end game over nothing the designer
of pac-man
not only did he never think anyone would
get to the end he didn't know where the
end was
he didn't know at what point the game
would run out of memory everything to
him is completely baffling they never
saw the split screen until i sent it to
them
messiah nakamoto who's the godfather of
video games
he crowned me video game player of the
century for that and all the previous
achievements
it doesn't get any higher than that
[Music]
[Music]
hey jillian do you like roller coasters
i love roller coasters and there's an
amusement park in italy i am dying to
check out this guy bruno built these
roller coasters by hand with no training
no motors he said he was inspired by the
movement of nature let's go for a ride
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tempo
[Music]
for this next story we're going to go to
nigeria to meet a woman named sandra and
sandra is the first female mechanic in
nigeria and she's teaching other women
to work on cars and a whole lot more
let's check out our great big story
[Music]
oh lady mechanic one big family one big
sister would
and we love our hands to be dirty our
fingers to be dirty we are together and
we are physicals around the world
[Music]
all right make sure you do your you have
your homework done
i need to see the papers
all right then good luck my name is
sandra aguibo
i'm the first female mechanic in nigeria
and the founder of the lady mechanic
initiative i've been a mechanic for 32
years
and i've been running my own garage for
22 years now so that is the way it works
the lady mechanic initiative is working
with the vulnerable group
the house commercial sex workers
this could drop out
married women wants to acquire skill
they're like there's no more hope in my
life i said to them you know what you
have got a lot of hope i'm going to help
you build that hope i'm in here she has
five children and she's a mechanic
amazing
because they are vulnerable
they don't have money they are from poor
background so they don't pay to lend and
we do all this from the funders funders
pay their stipend pay for their lecture
overall and my training is just free of
charge
you want to be able to help other women
as well
now we've been able to empower graduated
by a thousand female mechanics in
nigeria in five states
being the first human mechanic in
nigeria is not afraid of roses
men have been there from generation to
generation
fixing cars
when i came in it was like excuse me are
you okay or you need to see a doctor
but no i knew what i was doing but for
me to become the first female mechanic
in nigeria i had to work five times
other than the way the man will walk
to prove myself many people that don't
know me by my name is lady mechanic
everywhere i go
now a lot of guests wants to come to
nigeria to learn
how to fix cars
it's the best job in the world for any
woman i see
[Music]
well guys i hope you enjoyed these four
great big stories thanks for watching
subscribe by clicking on the horse above
us and make sure to comment because we
want to hear from you and we'll see you
real soon
bye guys